ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément loin de paris
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus se taire ils
ont des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
aujourd'hui je me rends à
saint-pierre-du-mont dans le département
des landes
[Musique]
bonjour mélanie merci de nous accueillir
alors pas de souci pas de souci il fait
beau à brume matinale s'est dispersé
bienvenue dans les landes avec un beau
soleil on va dire vous êtes déjà au
boulot oui oui allez donc là on va les
auxerre c'est sa vie c'est ça on va
faire les récoltes pour le marché donc
voilà on va aller ramasser des choux
chinois qui semblent en a récolté et on
va les préparer et c est après peut-être
on ira ramasser quelques radis en
fonction des commandes donc ici vous
avez repris en fait mélanie
l'exploitation familiale
pas tout à fait en fait je me suis
installée de mon côté en 2013 non
j'avais 23 ans et en fait on a décidé de
dissocier le maraîchage bio de l'autre
structure qui existait déjà de par mes
parents parce que il est en grandes
cultures
il n'y avait pas du tout de bio sur les
cotations d'accord et vous avez décidé
de vous lancer dans le bio
oui par choix j'imagine oui oui d'entrée
moi je le savais que je voulais faire
d'agriculture biologique
j'ai fait des études pour donc après il
fallait juste mettre en pratique on va
dire et pour vous c'est important de
faire du bio le choix du bio c'est
vraiment une volonté de ma part je pense
que je suis incapable de voilà de mettre
un produit voilà chimiques ou un intrant
chimique sur sûr mais sol
d'autant plus que je savais que je
voulais faire de la vente directe donc
quand vous avez client en face et que
vous savez que vous avez émis un produit
voilà pas très saine pour
l'environnement et même pour lui et puis
tout d'abord pour moi aussi je me voyais
mal partir dans ce circuit il a donc
vraiment le bio c'est vraiment une
volonté de ma part et c'est ce qui fait
toute la différence aussi au niveau
qualitatif je pense de légumes que je
produis quoi c'est plus compliqué de
travailler en bio oui oui vraiment que
c'est un peu le jour et la nuit par
rapport à mes collègues maraîchers qui
font du conventionnel on bascule
totalement vers une autre méthode vers
d'autres méthodes d'autres méthodes de
travail pardon et
avec une compréhension du sun qui n'est
pas du tout la même jusqu'à présent le
sol était un support pour femmes à
l'agriculteur est en fait moi c'est pas
qu'un support c'est lui qui va me
permettre d'avoir de donner la vie en
gros à mes légumes
donc il faut vraiment le bichonner en
prendre soin l'amendé et c'est pour
qu'ils me rendent le plus possible en
permanence soit pour comparaison donc
sur cinq hectares actuellement donc là
on a six employés donc six salariés pour
5 hectares cultivés et je pense que mes
collègues en conventionnel ils sont à
3,4 en fonction des circuits courts de
commercialisation qui met en place ça
veut dire que moi je vois 2 août voire
trois personnes supplémentaires en
charland gros supplémentaires sur
l'exploitation
quand on marche un peu sur la tête dans
la paix dans la production intensive
mais un petit peu moi c'est ce que je
dénonce un petit peu sur vraiment la
culture intensive c'est à dire que
franchement à 30 kilomètres d'ici on a
une culture on a des cultures de carotte
qui sont mis en place de manière
industrielle avec derrière aussi d une
éthique sociale qui est pas du tout
respecté parce que ce sont des
travailleurs étrangers qui sont mis dans
les champs même pour faire de la carotte
bio et en plus de ça vous avez un
gaspillage vous avez une normalisation
faire on n'est pas du tout sûr les mêmes
schémas de production donc en fait on on
est en train encore de déconnecter
davantage de le système quoi est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce processus
et en quoi ça vous ça vous coûte
et qu'est ce que ça vous rapporte moi je
suis pas là que pour produire les thés
pour les touristes qui sont là pour la
cote quoi je suis vraiment là pour
nourrir des familles tout au long de
l'année avec des légumes de saison et
des légumes bio pour vraiment un maximum
de familles
donc du coup une fois qu'on a ça en tête
et qu'on connaît un peu de monde
agricole et qu'on voit ce qui se passe à
30 kilomètres d'ici on se dit c'est pas
possible ce qu'on est en train de mettre
en place
et quand je vois mes collègues
agriculteurs qui gagnent pas leur vie et
qui sont vraiment ou même mes parents
dans le système agricole avec des pieds
et mains liés moi d'entrer je sais je
savais que je ne voulais pas ça et je ne
savais pas trop comment j'allais arriver
pour pas comment faire pour pas tomber
dans ce système là mais je savais que je
voulais être indépendante de pas mal de
choses et donc petit à petit j'ai
construit voilà le modèle qui a
aujourd'hui ça s'est pas fait et voilà
de manière hyper facile je galère je
vais galérer encore m haies mais c'est
vrai que je suis contente de ce système
là où je suis indépendante c'est moi qui
choisis mes fournisseurs
simon qui choisis mon calendrier de
production c'est moi qui choisis mais
variété et qui décide du système de
commercialisation quoi peut pas être
trop gourmand et il faut voilà savoir un
petit peu
trouver l'équilibré et pas vouloir
mouiller de grossir trop vite
allez hop
l'agriculture bio et le maraîchage bio
il ya sept ans ou 80
maintenant tout le monde en parle mais
en terme de technicité
on a encore des progrès à faire c'est à
dire que moi je me forme tout seul est
plus ou moins en permanence parce que au
niveau du département
il n'ya pas d'encadrement quoi et dans
les arrêts technicité pour pour que les
récoltes soit plus efficace pour perdre
moins de légumes moins de temps aussi
c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça de temps
d'énergie d'efficacité est vraiment ne
pas perdre des récoltes quoi donc en
fait
en fait il a fallu vraiment que je me
forme que je ferme tout l'équipe au fur
et à mesure et donc ça ça demande du
temps de l'énergie aie jugé essuyé pas
mal de pertes dès le départ de mes
productions quoi allez on va continuer
le circuit du légume c'est ça alors
donc là on va finir mettre en place les
choux donc là c'est l'ensemble des
légumes
voilà c'est un petit échantillon excuses
mais pour la petite vente qu'on fait de
temps en temps c'est vraiment pour
satisfaire un petit peu des légumes que
les gens n'ont pas l'habitude de voir
habituellement dans les supermarchés ou
même sur les marchés classiques quoi
donc là vous avez des blettes de
couleurs là vous avez des petits choux
chinois une autre variété que celui-ci
des petits choux fleurs gelées
vous avez des carottes aussi différente
à l'europe de couleurs donc vous avez
choisi vous d'être très indépendante
on l'a vu comment ça fonctionne à
bénéficier d'un peu de dettes de la pac
mais très très peu comment ça fonctionne
et pourquoi vous en avez très peu comme
ça donc sur les critères les aides de la
pac a en fait elles sont elles sont
attribuées à l'hectare et paiement de
base sont attribués à l'hectare donc un
gros plus vous avez d'hectares plus vous
avez des deux packs et ensuite donc ça
c'est sur le premier pilier est ensuite
depuis quelques années il ya une
deuxième pilier qui lui attribue des
aides
aux cultures ou au mode de production
donc si vous êtes un bio vous avez des
aides supplémentaires
si vous faites de la diversification
culturelle vous avez des aides
supplémentaires et c est en fait l'enjeu
de la pac 2 2 même c'est de savoir si on
continue à flécher les aides sur ceux
qui ont le plus d'hectares où si on
flèche un peu les aide sur le deuxième
pilier en améliorant les pratiques
environnementales et pratiques
culturales et en poussant vers l'ère des
techniques un peu différente
combien d'hectares ici les combien dead
au final moi sur mon exploitation
donc moi sur ma déclaration pac il ya à
peu près 5 hectares et de mémoire je
pense que je suis à 2500 euros des deux
packs sur sur l'année voilà pratiquement
rien quoi
non maintenant quand on sait que quand
même en france le revenu de
l'agriculteur c'est allé plus de 50%
souvent 60% qui viennent de la pac
oui ça dépend des structures mais c'est
vrai que plus on a une grosse
exploitation pu plus vous êtes aidez à
des heureusement un p'tit kawa
ça va faire du bien c'est pas
obligatoire là le masque on a la chance
de travailler sans je suis un peu
rebelle donc
je ne mets pas même pour la vente donc
donc des aides
oui mais que vous puissiez être libre de
faire ce que vous voulez de planter ce
que vous voulez les aides ll en soit
elle vous en chaîne s'est pas les aides
qui vous entraîne forcément les aides
elles ont été créés pour d'une part pour
amener de l'alimentation pâte pas cher à
la clientèle en fait pour nourrir la
france et pour l'europe pour avoir une
alimentation de base accessible en fait
pour le consommateur là où le système
est vicieux c'est les grosses firmes
comme on qu'on connaît tous française
qui capte la valeur ajoutée et qui
continueront engraisser le système est
pâle et pas des producteurs et en fait
ça ça vient de là nous localement par
exemple on a des appels des cultures
contractuels je peux si je peux les
citer il ya des grosses boîtes comme
bonduelle d'aussi que vous connaissez
tout ce qui fonde des légumes pour la
conserve donc une grosse partie des
productions sont plantés dans les landes
et donc vous signez un contrat entre
vous agriculteurs et
la marque mais entre temps il ya un
intermédiaire qui est une coque ou un
privé et en fait c'est ce contrat qui
vous dicte votre manière de faire c'est
là où c'est vicieux parce que dans le
contrat on vous impose tous les
traitements que vous devez faire on vous
impose la variété on vous impose la date
de semis et c'est donc celle là où vous
retrouvez les pieds et mains liés avec
le contrat certes il ya une réu peut y
avoir une rémunération derrière mais
elle est de plus en plus aléatoire et
elle est depuis en plus faible quoi ça
fait trente ou quarante ans que le
système on le connaît qu'il est en place
que rien a forcément rien n'a bougé
parce que
les agriculteurs sont pas plus riches on
mange toujours pas très bien notamment
dans les cantines etc
il n'y a pas grand-chose qui ont bougé
mais je pense que là aujourd'hui il ya
eu un déclic dans la population et il va
vraiment falloir que les politiques
enclenchent quelque chose quoi ça va pas
il faut pas que ce soit vraiment un coup
dur en lisant demande et on ferme la
grogne du sist agro industrie on a
réduit zine et vous partez au chômage
non il faut accompagner la transition il
faut vraiment accompagner les
agriculteurs à changer leurs méthodes
par des moyens de paiements directs sur
les aides qui ou sur les transitions qui
met en place et aider les filières a
changé un peu leur vision donc si vous
aviez un voeu un souhait pour la france
idéale
ça serait vraiment que les paysans ne
gagnent leur vie quoi il le mérite
vraiment mélanie enfin photos ont conclu
toujours la séquence comme ça on va la
faire dans la fête dans la serre ça
sympa c'est ça sera à l'abri un petit
peu aller dans les petits choux voilà
c'est jacques dessange
[Musique]